For well over a decade,
the Marvel Cinematic Universe
has brought the comic
world to the big screen
using state-of-the-art visual effects
and elaborate stunts.
Making a Marvel movie is
physically demanding work
for the actors and the
people behind the cameras.
To learn how these movies come to life,
let's take a look at
what eight Marvel movies
looked like behind the scenes.
The third "Captain
America" movie went big.
It was the first film ever
to employ IMAX 2D cameras,
which came in handy during
the now legendary airport battle.
For one daring jump,
a stunt performer attached to a rope
leaped right behind Bucky
to capture this shot.
For another shot,
they actually flipped a truck over.
The sequence where Cap
faces off against Crossbones
and falls out of a window
and then onto an awning, a truck,
and then finally the ground
took a lot of planning.
Stunt coordinator Sam Hargrave,
who also doubled for Cap at times,
said pulling this off
involved constructing
an awning and shipping dock
for the existing building.
The awning had to be built
at just the right angle,
and all the pads had to be obscured.
"Doctor Strange" took the
MCU visually to a new level.
The multiverse involved intense CGI work.
Framestore alone worked on
365 visual effects shots for the film.
So, naturally, there was a lot of
green screen and empty spaces on set,
like when Doctor Strange
walks through this portal
into another dimension.
On set, he was really walking
through what looked like
a giant glowing Hula-Hoop.
Meanwhile, elaborate wire work
was used to give the appearance
the characters were
floating through the air.
And when Strange takes on his astral form,
the visual effects team
backlit everything.
This helped them more easily create
a transparent effect.
And what about Strange's
fateful car crash?
According to director Scott Derrickson,
they had to destroy about
nine real Lamborghinis
for this one scene.
Unsurprisingly, outer space
in the sequel to "Guardians of the Galaxy"
looked a lot like a blue screen.
One of the most subtle touches in the film
was the de-aging done to Kurt Russell
for the opening flashback.
While they did do some makeup touch-ups
to make him look younger,
it was largely CGI.
A young actor was used for
reference of 30-year-old skin
and stood in for Russell on set.
Visual effects artists later grafted
some of the stand-in's
skin onto the older actor.
And how do you act alongside
a CGI character like Baby Groot?
With this Baby Groot doll,
which gave the cast a better idea
of how they should make eye contact
with Baby Groot in a given scene.
Actors Bradley Cooper and Vin Diesel
recorded the voices of
Rocket and Baby Groot
in a sound booth.
Their facial expressions and gestures
were also recorded and used for reference
when animating the characters.
In "Black Panther," the
cast's rigorous training
in fighting styles ranging
from judo to jujitsu
is on full display throughout the film.
Actor Michael B. Jordan
was covered in about
3,000 prosthetic dots.
Each one was made with
a glue-like material.
The makeup team had to make sure
they wouldn't all come off
during the Warrior Falls sequence,
given that it was a fight scene involving
a lot of body contact and splashing water.
"Black Panther" was
shot all over the world.
Many of the Wakanda scenes were filmed
on a soundstage in Atlanta,
while the car chase through
the streets of Busan
was actually filmed in South Korea.
According to cinematographer
Rachel Morrison,
they wanted to distinguish
Wakanda visually
from the rest of the world.
One way they did that: lighting.
For the Wakanda scenes,
Morrison said they relied
on warm afternoon light
and used supplemental light
to get rid of any shadows.
"Avengers: Infinity War"
contains approximately
2,900 visual effects shots.
Thanos is a motion-capture marvel.
Bringing a CGI character
with over 40 minutes
of screen time to life
was a big challenge.
At times, actor Josh Brolin would wear
a Thanos head on top of his own head
so the actors could use
this eyeline as a guide.
Brolin wore a motion-capture suit,
tracking marks on his face,
and a helmet with cameras attached to it
to get every subtle mannerism.
In this sequel, Scott
Lang fought alongside
Hope Van Dyne, aka the Wasp.
She made a big impression early on
during this fight
sequence in a restaurant.
The stunt team went
through four to five weeks
of intense training for it.
Evangeline Lilly worked with them
to tweak the character's moves
to fit the actress' own movements.
For example, Lilly thought to add a lot of
S curves into her fighting style.
Giant-Man was, of
course, created with CGI.
But for the part where he
collapses into the water,
they had sprinklers on set
to actually splash onlookers.
Then there is the stunning quantum realm.
When building this microscopic world,
the visual effects team made sure
to give it a psychedelic feel.
Everything in this environment
was constantly in motion.
To make such a tiny world
seem so much bigger,
they relied heavily on macrophotography.
Other photography devices
such as lens flares
added to the energetic visuals.
Oscar winner Brie Larson
got in superhero shape
to portray the titular hero.
Larson worked with celebrity
trainer Jason Walsh
for nine months before "Captain
Marvel" started shooting.
By the end of their time together,
she was strong enough to
be able to push a Jeep,
so she was more than
ready for shots like this.
And how do you make Captain Marvel fly?
Sometimes they used wires.
Other times they used a tuning-fork rig,
which was operated by
crew members in blue suits
who would be edited out later.
"Captain Marvel" also
features some of the MCU's
most convincing de-aging work to date.
The visual effects team was tasked
with making Samuel L. Jackson
look like his 1990s self.
Nick Fury has a lot of screen time.
There are at least 800
de-aging shots in the film,
and the artists had to take
nearly three decades off of him.
While filming, Jackson donned a wig
and tracking dots on his face.
In postproduction,
they got to work reshaping and
resculpting the actor's face
while altering the texture of his skin.
Luckily, they had a lot
of reference material
of 1990s-era Jackson to work off of.
To play the updated version of Thor,
chiseled star Chris
Hemsworth wore a bodysuit,
which he estimated
weighed 60 to 70 pounds,
as well as a mouthpiece
that puffed out his cheeks.
While the visual effects
team did some touch-ups,
Marvel Entertainment visual
effects producer Jen Underdahl
said that actually having the suit on set
helped Hemsworth's performance.
And for this one shot,
you will notice the
actors weren't actually
wearing their nanotech suits on set.
That is because it made more
sense to create these suits
largely using visual effects.
Since they constantly expand and shrink,
it would be hard to do that practically.
Nothing compared to the
film's final battle.
Bringing this many characters
together in one place
was a logistical challenge.
Not every actor could
actually be there on set
at the same time.
Take this shot, where the MCU's
female heroes stood together.
Tom Holland couldn't be there on that day.
Because Peter Parker hands Captain Marvel
the Infinity Gauntlet,
they needed to have somebody there
to interact with Brie Larson.
So another actor stood in for him,
and Holland was later
digitally added into the scene.
Thanks for watching.
If you liked this video,
subscribe for more just like it.
Let us know what other Marvel movies
you wanna know more about in the comments.